[Music]
risk
risk is our business
that's what the starship is all about
that's why we're aboard her
[Music]
captain kirk is boldly and genuinely
going to space nearly 250 years before
the time of the original star trek if
you follow me we learned yesterday that
william shatner now 90 years old will
travel on the next blue origin space
flight due to liftoff one week from
today he says it is never too late to
experience new things which is true this
morning a russian rocket by the way
carried another actor into orbit and
she's ready to turn the international
space station into a movie set as our
liz palmer reports
if all goes well this launch
will make movie history aboard that
rocket
after a summer of training our actor
julia perezild director and cameraman
clem schapienko and cosmonaut anton
cleoplayerov their mission to shoot a
movie about a surgeon pitta sild who
goes into space to save an astronaut's
life well it's a stunt professor ian
christie a russian movie expert says the
project is at least partly political
it's no coincidence that massive
publicity around the movie comes just as
the kremlin's struggling with a lethal
covet surge and president putin's
popularity is sagging undoubtedly it is
propaganda it wouldn't have got the
backing
because the state's paying for the whole
thing yeah yeah to distract if you like
from other you know bad news there's
plenty of that around obviously this is
star city outside moscow where the film
crew trained wow it really is small i
know from a visit a few years ago just
how cramped they'll be in the soyuz
capsule flying them to the international
space station there they'll shoot in
zero gravity alongside the scientists
already living and working there
in hollywood space is classic
blockbuster material
think gravity
i'm good to go and it was a hollywood
rumor about tom cruise planning a movie
in space with elon musk that fired up
the russians
of course the competitive element is
there says the movie's director tom
cruise also really wants to do this
russia has had big wins in the space
race with america the first dog in orbit
the first man and woman
and now the first movie
but there's more to it than one
upsmanship we can be cynical but i think
we should also recognize that it sort of
speaks to something that has this deep
roots in russian culture a belief that
yes
man should reach the stars
but then he and she must return to earth
they've already practiced the landing to
face the next critical challenge at the
box office
for cbs morning's elizabeth palmer
london
and while they're doing that william
shatner is going up in space i'm excited
for wave shatner he's totally right
you're never too old to experience new
things so i wonder if scorsese and
spielberg and tarantino are sitting back
thinking
i'm next oh i'm sure they're already
right and they're writing the script
applications they're like please let me
up
we'll just be here to cheer them on well
i'll speak for myself no desire but i
applaud anybody who wants to go you're
right about that